Mein Name ist Eddie,
ähm, ich komme aus Scranton, Pennsylvania.
Ich habe gerade hier in diesem Gebäude gewählt.
Was haben Ihre Eltern beruflich gemacht
?
Mein Vater war Polizist. Ja, er ist
ein totaler Demokrat.
Ich meine, er war anders, die Demokraten
waren anders  Okay,
wir respektieren es. Ich hörte Präsident Kennedy
hier sprechen. Ja, als ich neun Jahre
alt war.
Okay, das war großartig. Alles, was Präsident
Kennedy ist
es ist nicht mehr so, mein vater, wenn
er noch am leben wäre, ich weiß,
er würde heute dieses jahr niemals den demokraten wählen, okay,
ja, er würde niemals, ich habe
für donald trump gestimmt,
sagte ich, weil ähm, ich glaube, er war für
amerika, ich glaube, er liebt amerika,
ähm er  Er ist für die Wirtschaft, er ist für das
Leben. Ich kann nicht für
Joe Biden stimmen. Ich glaube, dass
er von externen
Kräften
korrumpiert wurde
viel Geld
und sie wollen nicht das Beste
für dieses Land